- That's super tactical, but
I don't know where even to go.
Where do I start?
- What do you mean?
Go to eBay, completed
item, eBay app, search.
Literally, fucking I'm gonna show you.
- I'm so freakin' new at this.
- Ready?
You got your perspective.
I just wanna be happy.
Don't you wanna be happy?
(light music)
- Quite frankly, I think
my little brother sucks.
I think just straight
up the way we grew up
from how I grew up now is
completely totally different.
- Because things got better financially.
It happened with me, too.
I had to buy my car at a garage
sale, my younger brother...
My brother was 11 years younger than me,
what's the difference here?
- He's 15, I'm 26.
- Right, so 11 years, same shit.
I lived this life.
When I was 26, my brother
was 15, but you don't need
to cast judgment on your brother.
Of course, I thought my brother was soft.
I worked every minute--
- That's the thinking I
wanna change for myself.
- Yeah, don't cast judgment on him.
He's your fucking brother.
Spit knowledge to him, so
that he can think for himself,
but don't judge him.
- How do I get him to
listen to me, though?
- He's 15, he doesn't
give a fuck about you.
He's like, fuck you, bro, I got my shit.
I'll tell you how you get him to listen.
I didn't cast judgment on my brother.
I love my brother and I was
like this is what happens
in the streets, corporate
and then I let him.
If he feels you're
casting judgment on him,
if you're always playing the
you're soft, I had it hard,
he's not gonna listen.
If you're like, yo, I
just want you to be happy
because I love you,
let me tell you how this
looks or that looks,
now you're giving him
love instead of judgment.
Then he'll start listening to you
instead of saying fuck you, bro.
I don't need to hear you judging me.
I didn't control that I was born second.
- Because it goes deeper.
I'm his only positive
masculine energy in his life.
- Okay, I get it.
- Single mom, four kids--
- I get it.
- We're part of that group,
so it's like I was hustling
when I was his age--
- Look, look, look, look.
Listen, the hardest thing
is when you love somebody
and you're putting them on
also knowing it might make them
soft and they don't know how
to go earn for themselves.
That's a fine balance that
every brother, every sister,
every parent has to go through.
You just have to be thoughtful
about it and be patient
about it and also remember
how you were at 15.
He's got a million different
things going through his dome.
- That's pretty much
it, all I got, my man.
I appreciate you.
- Just love.
That's all I got, man.
- Really nice meeting you, man.
Real pleasure.
- So, right now, I have a fitness
app and I'm trying to work
on a fitness line and I
basically do everything myself.
We've been building my
website, everything.
My problem now is really
just finding a team
and finding people that
will actually care about it
as much as I do.
- They won't.
I know.
- Nobody should care about it.
If you want her or him to care as much,
give them 50% of the fucking business.
They shouldn't care as much,
and you gotta realize you work
for them, they don't work for you.
Scaling is about doing the
thing that everybody thinks,
reverse.
You work for them.
They shouldn't care.
I don't expect these guys
to care as much as I do.
You hire fast and you fire fast.
Speed.
You hire him, you think
he's gonna be great,
he sucks shit, you fire him.
You hire him, you think he's
gonna be great, he's great,
he gets to stay.
You hire her, you think
she's gonna be meh,
then she's fucking
awesome, she gets to stay.
It's about making decisions.
If you want it, that's what you gotta do.
- Obviously, content, content, content.
I'm watching a company that's
based on all of this stuff,
all the hype, all the fashion focus.
Is there anything else
that you would recommend
to accentuate my brand?
- More.
- Just more content?
- More content.
- It's so simple.
- It's so simple, but nobody
wants to wait nine years.
- I know.
- You don't wanna wait nine years.
- Yeah.
- I'm in this for the absolute long run.
- So, there is no other secret.
There's make content and
be good at distribution
and keep watching new platforms
and do it on every platform
and rinse and repeat.
- At this point, we have
22,000 followers on Instagram--
- Whether you said zero or 22 million,
it would still be the same answer.
- It's the same shit.
So, you're doing better
than somebody who has seven,
not as good as somebody who has 49
and that doesn't even mean
anything in the first place.
It's just constant motion to
what you're trying to achieve,
which I assume is for it
to be a sustainable thing
for you to live your life
by doing what you love.
- Yeah.
- Well, if you wanna do that...
People use followers
or dollars as metrics.
To me, it's just about being
able to be sustainable.
When I was building Wine Library,
what I needed was $40,000
a year to pay my $2,000
rent and buy nothing else
and that's what was sustainable,
so I was able to take
every other dollar to
build bigger Wine Library.
- It's not about getting some fancy shit.
- I don't give a fuck
about some 22,000 followers
or $22 million.
You can make $22 million a year
and spend 24 million
and go out of business.
- Yes, exactly.
- Sustainability, got it?
- Alright, I appreciate that.
- You got it.
How are you?
- Pleasure to meet you.
- Good, how are things?
- Things are amazing.
It's a great thing to
be here and to see you.
- Thank you.
- I have one question in regards
to I hear you preach a lot
about just knowing you
and doing your thing,
be great at that one thing.
I recently came across the term polymath,
which I realize is really
more what I'm about.
My entire life, I've never
been able to just focus
on that one thing.
If I get mad satisfaction
from that one thing,
I always gotta then
shift to another thing.
- I'm kind of life that.
- Yeah, I see that very much
and my question would be
when you're a solopreneur,
and you're trying to build up
and branch out in that
regard, how do you delegate--
- Put 100% of your energy
into something that takes 80%
of the macro, so that it
gives you the stability
to go be conspicuous with your other 20%.
I always had Wine Library or
Vayner Media as a foundation
that allowed me to be ridiculous
about everything else.
Then it becomes practical.
Otherwise, if you never
create a foundation,
then you're vulnerable.
- So, pick the thing that's
gonna be the most practical
to start, build that, make
it solid and then dabble
in everything else and let
those build up over time?
- I like that, yeah.
Each shit to build a
foundation, to let you play
in perpetuity.
- I've been a really big fan of you.
You really inspired me.
- Thank you.
A couple months ago, I started
an entrepreneurship club
at my school and I got
everybody come to ComplexCon.
- I love it.
- I have a question.
When I grow up, I wanna
be a clothing designer,
like Virgil and Sean Witherspoon.
And I was wondering what
would be your advice--
- Go intern for Virgil or Sean.
Your whole life right now
should be about getting
internships from people
that you wanna be like
cause because the closer
you get to the sun,
the more likely you could become it.
Your whole life for the
next eight years should be
about interning for the people
that you want to become.
It's the number one move.
You understand?
- Yes.
Cool, do that and you're gonna
start with Virgil and Shawn
and they're not gonna reply
to your DM, but you're gonna
hit up Jerry DiLorenzo, couldn't
get Lorenzo, next, next,
next, but somebody's gonna say yes.
And you start at the
number 44 person you wanted
and then next summer, you get to number 22
because you worked for number 44, right?
Champion wasn't fresh
three years ago, right?
So, be smart, you understand?
- Thank you so much.
- You're welcome.
I really appreciate it.
(upbeat music)
- As a new flipper, what
product do you think I should--
- Everything, at night,
you should be laying in bed
at night searching hats.
How do you think I figured out Muglife?
I was like I see a lot
of mugs at garage sales.
Do mugs sell for anything?
Search on eBay, mugs,
completed items, sold,
sort by fucking price.
Holy shit!
There's $88 mugs, there's
$63 mugs, there's $96 mugs?
Then go buy a bunch of mugs
for a quarter, come home,
look them up, educate, educate, educate.
The key to flip life is the
homework you do at night
from 10 to midnight during
the week that you fucking then
leverage on Saturday when you kill it
with your fucking knowledge.
- That's freakin tactical.
That's super tactical, but I
don't know where even to go.
Where do I start?
- What do you mean?
Go to eBay, completed items,
search eBay app, search.
Literally, fucking I'm gonna show you.
- I'm so freaking new at this.
Ready?
eBay, right?
Now, you're going to garage
sales, you're like, oh shit,
I see a lot of salt and pepper shakers.
Salt and pepper shakers, you're
like, I see a lot of them.
Then, you go to filter,
sold and completed items,
sort, highest price and
then you're like, oh shit!
- Oh shit!
(laughs)
- $441, 600, 1,000.
This little bird is 325 bucks.
You're not buying this little fucking bird
at a fucking garage
sale if you don't know.
It's $350.
- Who bought this for $350--
- Salt and pepper shaker
fucking collectors.
Why would people buy sneakers for 500?
They collect them.
Why do people buy shirts?
Why do people by bracelets?
They like them.
People buy everything,
everything can be flipped.
- Got you.
Got it.
- But that's the homework.
- That's it.
You go to garage sales,
you go to thrift stores,
you see a lot of things.
By the way, that's what
you used to have to do.
Now, you can just do it at
the fucking garage sale.
You're like, let me look
that up in their mouth,
in the person's mouth,
you're just looking it up
in their face.
- For sure, got it.
Thanks, Gary.
- You got it.